and now it's time for bombing reviews
and if Chester a bum
tonight's review Harry Potter and the
half-blood Prince there's this kid
called Harry Potter he's a magician
attend it so he goes to make judgments
go to become a with a matter o we to be
you a new then this you saw the other
fields let me quickly send them up for
you one but was it cool don't do
something strange is going on by like
that round three something strange is
going on might still don't know what
down for something strange is going on
it I still don't know what fell by
something strange is going on and I
don't know what all I can think about
these girls six I don't care what's
going on I just need to get laid I son
so Harry goes back to with matured
school begins it takes month it used to
belong to the half-blood Prince fucking
coincidence
half of my blood is from the artist
formerly known as Prince no you don't
want to know how I guess she's really a
vampire Chihuahua so an Aries is trying
to find out about this bed with your
called Baltimore's because both of our
entire bodies like people burn down
houses
we don't need Harry Potter we need
Rainbow Brite and all her multicolored
friends which ironically all white so
Harry is enough with Ron Weasley sister
right Weasley sit fairies in love with
some other boy rather we need to know it
some other girl Wow hurt my knees in
love with Ron Weasley and some jock kid
is in love with her money I'd say
triangle legs were like a love octagon
oh yeah that's way so Harry finds out
that Snape and Malfoy might be bad guys
and I was like whoa you mean the people
who dress in black and do evil things
are bad guys - problem Harry becomes
extremely lucky because he drinks this
lotion and I like yeah what I first up
on my United Kingdom sci-fi comedies
isn't everybody
so Aaron is with a matter called double
doofus go and try to find the trick in a
Baltimore and they have to travel it's
like this big scary cave where double
dippers had to drink all this potion and
he's like in this liquid makes me a
crazy just force me to drink more that's
what I say every time I enter a bar for
example I can make any drug disappeared
well can eat it in certain I don't care
I'll make it happen so don't do this
before turns back to the school and how
do I put this
I don't want giving anything away but I
and it was the healthiest Harry Potter
ever except there was things possible
happen just like me this is Joey
yeah